-Senator, you're obviously
an expert debater.
You were a debate star
back in school
and you've held your own i
every Democratic debate so far
So we thought we'd put
your skills to the test
to make sure you're ready
for any question
that's thrown your way.
-All right.
-It's time for "Curveball"
with Senator Elizabeth Warren.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now Senator, some of thes
questions will be ones
you've heard before,
but some are going to be
extremely hard-hitting.
-Okay.
-Designed to catch you off guard
and expose the truth.
-Okay, I'm ready.
-The only rule is that you hav
to answer right away with
whatever pops in your head
-Okay.
-All right. Here we go.
-I'm ready.
-Can we lower the lights?
♪♪♪♪
So we do make it very intense.
Yeah.
-Yeah. This is a little creepy
-All right. Sorry about that
-Okay.
-Yeah. Sorry.
-Okay, I'm ready.
-What is the most importan
issue
facing American voters today
-Corruption.
-What would you do
on day one of your presidency?
-Uh, I would make sure
that we lower the price
of prescription drugs and that
we stopped all new mining
and oil drilling
on federal lands.
We got to protect
our environment.
[ Air horn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Curveball!
-Curveball.
What's Baby Yoda's whole deal,
and why are people
so excited about him?
[ Laughter ]
-He's a baby,
and babies are cute.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
-That's very good. Very good
You did that one. All right.
[ Clears throat ]
Do you want to abolish
the electoral college?
-Yes.
-How would you deal with
the national debt?
-Ask the millionaires
and billionaires
to pay a couple of cents more.
Come on, guys.
And then let's make real
investments in America's future.
That's how we build an economy
that works for everyone.
[ Air horn blows ]
-Curveball!
-Do you agree some birds
are too big?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Which ones?
-Any bird bigger than Big Bird
-Oh, yeah.
[ Bell dings ]
That's good.
Double curveball on that one
-All right.
Is it possible to reverse
climate change in our lifetimes?
-Yes, but we have to have
the political courage
to take on all of the mone
and power
that's now embedded
in Washington
that's keeping anybody
from making moves on this.
[ Air horn blows ]
-Curveball!
-Should there be a "Ballers"
movie,
or were you satisfied
with the series finale?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh,
anything that The Rock
wants to do. Always.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Correct.
Which past president
do you admire most?
-Uh, Franklin Roosevelt.
-Why aren't you taking money
from big donors?
-Because I think that government
already works well for
millionaires and billionaires.
I want a government that
works better for everybody else,
and I think the way we start
that is in a Democratic primary.
You ought to finance it
from the grass roots up.
-What's something --
-Elizabethwarren.com.
[ Laughter ]
-What's something you wish you
could say to your younger self
-Uh, don't take it so hard
It's all gonna work out.
[ Air horn blows]
-Curveball!
-Do you know who Van Halen is?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, but you don't have to.
Let's ease up on Billy.
[ Laughter ]
-Very nice.
Senator Warren, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's safe to say
you're ready
for whatever questions the
throw at you in the next debate.
My thanks again to
Senator Elizabeth Warren!